oh there it is it's been a while let's
see how it's doing
all right
let's see oh yeah it looks in good shape
oh that's where my flashlight went i
forgot i left it here
look at these spider skins
they're huge
look at this
these are where spiders have been
molting out of their shell to get ever
bigger look at that oh here's another
one
spider kin yeah those are spider kit
skins look at that
oh
there must be some big spiders up here
oh there he is
i found him
he's been getting bigger and bigger
there's his old skin
oh yeah he's big see how we're gonna do
this
there we go got rid of him one out of
our house
yeah oh there's another one
there's the
come on
come on
how'd you go
oh you found a little baby one yeah yeah
let's see
oh i bet there's just tons of them in
here
look at this
what is this thing up here
it is huge
the size of that
it's a it's a chrysalis
it's where a woolly caterpillar
turned into a butterfly well i gotta say
i'm pretty proud this thing's holding up
really well it's been almost a year
since i started building it looks great
we've been gone all summer long we did
the longest road trip in the united
states where we drove ten thousand four
hundred miles uh basically from key west
florida to dead horse alaska
and uh
yeah so i haven't been here in months uh
but uh things look good
all right let's check out the toilet
oh
it looks in good shape
yeah
doesn't seem to be full of snakes or
raccoons or giant spiders so that's good
daddy built that toilet
do you think that's funny yeah well this
has been a pretty awesome project but
we're getting pretty close to done on a
list of all the things i wanted to do
but i've got a few little repairs and
improvements we need to accomplish here
in the next few days
one problem we have is we've got sparks
coming out of the chimney and melting
the tarp that's not good so we need to
fix that before winter comes also we
need to repair some of the chinking in
here there's places where the mud is
particularly thick and it's falling out
after it dried so i think we need to go
ahead and repair that and there's quite
a few places where the mud is popped out
additionally i'd like to insulate the
roof somehow really make it nice and
toasty warm in here another thing i'd
really like is a workbench or a counter
because whenever i cook or i'm working
on projects i'm having to lay on the
ground and bend over and it kills my
back so i'd really like to have a way to
be able to cook and work
with a countertop and finally i need to
chop up a load of firewood i should have
a stack of firewood that goes all the
way to the roof here to get ready for
winter time well before i get to any of
these chores i've got to do one thing
for jacob we've got to roast
marshmallows don't we yeah
i really like most smells
ah why don't you go find a good
marshmallow stick and i'll get a fire
going
let's get some sticks going
here's a dick thanks bud
one chocolate marshmallow coming up
okay give that a go
all right i think the first project i
want to tackle is getting a work bench
because that'll make doing dinner a
whole lot easier and i think i want to
put it right here it's nice and close to
the fire
[Music]
so
[Music]
well there we go we got it done they're
not at standard height but i'm not a
standard man so
yes this will work perfectly
awesome i'm hungry so we're gonna get
dinner started i'm gonna use my brand
new countertops
all right we're going to be making some
pizza tonight
this is going to be awesome this is a
fun little recipe
got a little yeast a little water and
let it sit for five minutes once the
yeast is activated then we're gonna
knead it in the dough
yeah you think that's gonna make yummy
pizza
all right
all right there we go we got the pizza
sandwich between two cookie sheets now
we're gonna bake it
all right let's see
see what we got
oh
that doesn't look too bad a pizza oh you
want to eat that pizza yeah
that actually turned out really well
it could be i'm so hungry but that
tastes good
oh that was so good you like your pizza
yeah that's good stuff isn't it
are you pooping
[Music]
we've got full bellies we're tired it's
late i'm gonna get to bed because we've
got a lot of work to do in the morning
i'll see you guys in the morning
well good morning
we had an okay night's sleep got a
little cold this morning and we're gonna
get some warm breakfast in us and
that'll help warm us up a little bit
starting a new fire on old warm coals is
really easy you take a big bundle of
sticks and place it over your coals and
it traps that heat you put your tinder
underneath and just let it sit for a few
minutes the heat from the coals dries
out your tinder makes it even better
then after a few minutes just blow it on
a little bit poof
it lights up so easy because it's been
preheated
all right let's get some oatmeal cooking
you guys haven't seen these before these
are shelf life milks
they uh don't require any refrigeration
until you open them and they last months
and i take these out camping when i'm
with jacob because he's still really
little like it likes his comfort milk
you know so
that'll be for his breakfast ain't fancy
but it is a classic
instant oatmeal
there we go
hey jake good morning are you ready for
some breakfast
here
use some oatmeal
spam and oatmeal it's a good combo
all right now that finished breakfast
time to get to work and i love my
countertop but it's not just a
countertop
it's a place to store firewood and keep
the snow off it and try to keep it a
little bit drier
so we need to fill it full of firewood
and it's going to take a lot of elbow
grease
uh
oh
got a lot of small and medium-sized
firewood but i need some big stuff good
pine
got a lot of dead pine trees here let's
start pulling them over and chopping
them up we're gonna haul them back and
chop them up over by the cabin
[Music]
[Music]
oh my goodness this is killing my arms
shall we go stack all this firewood up
[Music]
well there's a fair amount of firewood
not as much as i was hoping but a good
start well me and jake got a lot done
today look at that that is a healthy
pile of firewood
but two things have happened one
jacob's pooped like a bazillion times
and we kind of burned up our entire
allotment of diapers so we need to go
get more diapers and two jacob has been
saying he misses mommy wants to go home
is that right yeah i want to go home
right now
i think what we're gonna do is go home
get jacob changed let him see mama and
then tomorrow we're gonna come back and
finish this project and do some more
camping that sounds like a good plan
yeah and your camera poke my camera
broke yeah my my tripod broke look at
all those mosquito bites though you have
so many mosquito bites on your face
and in your eyeballs yeah let's go home
and get you a bath shall we
[Music]
all right we're gonna head home change
poopy diapers resupply i'm gonna get
back at this
well we're back at the house and it's
another day and i'm heading off to the
cabin to finish our project but i don't
think jacob's gonna come with me and
mama won't let me borrow her baby again
if i bring him back in this condition
look at that oh no
actually jacob's got a playdate with
some friends today apparently so
he's gonna stay and hang here and tommy
and nathan are at school so
it's just daddy
[Music]
[Music]
hey babe
hey sadie hey did you mean to leave your
bag of food and mosquito repellent on
the kitchen table
oh i left all of my food at home didn't
i
it looked like it ah
love you becca
love you sorry it's a little more than
two hours each way to get to the log
cabin and i'm already an hour and a half
away from home
i think i better swing by a grocery
store or something if i can find one
all right guys we're back and i'm
starving so i'm going to try to get some
lunch going
i found this tiny little country market
and grabbed a few supplies real quick
some yeast
some honey and butter and i've got
peppered pork jowls my splurge item was
they had a virginia dried country ham
oh it's been raining all morning and
everything's absolutely drenched i need
to find some dry kindling
try to find stuff that's
off the ground
[Music]
dead briars burn really well and they
stay pretty dry even in the rain they're
just a pain to harvest because of all
the thorns i got these big pieces of fat
wood in my fire starting kit basically
fat wood is pine wood with loads of pine
resin in it and pine resin burns really
well
smells super strong that pine smell you
get it from harvesting standing dead
wood all the tree dies and the sap
drains down into the stump and so on the
bottom of the the stump you can get all
this fat wood kind of the technique here
is hold your knife still and pull the
wood towards you keeps your shavings
from flying all over the place too much
when you hold a piece of fat wood that
your hand warms it up and starts to get
sticky that's when you know you got a
good piece
i have a cotton ball here soaked in a
little bit of vaseline
go and wrap that around the end of a
stick
make a little teeny tiny torch and i'm
going to ignite it with my blast match
i'm throwing a load of fat wood on this
fire i'm hungry i ain't messing around
all right
[Music]
a little yeast a little water a little
bread flour let that sit for five
minutes
while the bread's doing its thing i'm
gonna go ahead and work on the chimney
and try to make a spark arrester so when
i build the fire in the chimney every
once in a while a spark comes up lands
on my roof and melts my roof
additionally i'm getting a lot of rain
that's coming down in between the tarp
and the chimney and getting onto my
stove so i'm going to try to solve two
problems at once i got this little
chimney cap at the hardware store for a
few bucks and it's got this little rain
shield on there and that should help
deflect the rain a little bit and keep
less rain from going down along the
chimney pipe i also got this little
piece of mesh here that'll help screen
out some of the sparks it won't be
perfect but hopefully it'll help
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
slide this down over the chimney like
this
and test it out
and if the chimney seems like it's being
smothered not getting enough air
then i can raise it up a little bit so
there's a second gap in between the
chimney and here and that allow even
more smoke to escape so i can kind of
adjust it without having to re-cut the
mesh and if i don't need it at all well
then i just got a little bit of mesh
over my pipe it's not a big deal
well it's up there we'll see whether it
works or not
all right i got some warm water here
we're gonna add that to the
dough if you want nice fluffy bread
you've got to have wet dough if the
dough is too stiff the bubbles can't
make it expand after about 10 minutes
the dough is starting to feel just a
little bit rubbery and a little bit
drier
so we're gonna let it sit and rise we'll
let that sit for one hour and it should
double in size while the bread's rising
i'm gonna go ahead and seal up the holes
in the roof and i've got these little
squares of flex tape that i bought and
supposedly you can put this on wet
surfaces and it'll still adhere so
i'm going to go ahead and stick it over
all the little burn holes i can find
there we go peppered pork jowls
all right time to grill our jowls
ho ho
got a cooked pork jowl and our bread
boy smells really good
there you go
there's the bread
well that's hot
that is so good
but it is so hot
let's get some butter on that
that is so good
like salty peppered bacon
if you've ever eaten bacon and thought
to yourself i love this but it needs to
be bigger and fattier
pork jowls might be just your thing in
case you're wondering what pork jowls
are it's the cheeks of a pig
but not his butt his face
just trying to enjoy my dinner and the
rain gets started for realsies
can i get out of here
well i guess i'm finishing dinner in
here and it's really coming down and
there's some thunder going too
oh so good
but we got thunder and lightning and
heavy rain going on i'm gonna sit here
and hunker down and see if it passes
see what happens we only have a few
hours of daylight left
well it's been raining for about two
hours now and it's cozy i mean if i had
my little buddy here i would be curled
up with jacob and we'd be watching
movies it'd be no big deal but this is
lame by myself so
i'm not going to be able to get
everything done before sunset so i think
i'm just going to go home wait till the
weather gets a little better and come
back and finish the cheeking later
[Applause]
well i didn't get much done today but
i'm going to call it
hopefully you guys enjoy this make sure
to click subscribe if you want to see
more camping and outdoor adventure
videos from the outdoor boys youtube
channel
we're getting ready to do some really
extreme winter camping this year
and i think you guys are going to really
like the camping videos that are coming
up anyway thanks for watching see you
guys next saturday
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button and you'll get
notifications thanks for watching